[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle vidéo en compagnie
de Sophie bonjour Miss plume bonjour
Julien Miss plume qui est décidément
partout en ce moment et oui elle est sur
Youtube elle est sur twitch elle est
dans le courrier de la stne alors on va
vous mettre les liens dans la
description allez vous abonner à sa
chaîne twitch elle fait des lives oui de
subnautica en ce moment c'est subnautica
mais sinon je fais des lives sur la
conservation des espèces le mardi quand
j'ai le temps et et quand ça tombe le
mardi et quand ça
tombe et puis elle participe à à ce
gentil podcast le courrier de la sterne
euh donc si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur les oiseaux sur les dinosaures
modernes voilà B c'est un podcast mais
c'est toujours très intéressant en
compagnie de
euh de Florient du coup qui est pas
ornitologue mais du coup ornitologue
amateur et on fait plein de super super
vidéos ensemble VO toutes les semaines
donc si vous êtes si vous êtes assoifffé
de contenu Miss plume allez-y allez vous
abonner on vous met les liens dans la
description voilà et aujourd'hui
justement c'est thématique on va parler
des dinosaures et des oiseaux et de ce
qui et de ce qui les unit à travers
cette cet objet de curiosité qui est le
chikenosaurus donc le pouletosaur euh ce
fameux projet qui veut qui veut qui se
enfin qui qui est connu comme étant un
projet cherchant à ramener à la vie les
dinosaures en
désévoluant un oiseau plutôt que en
allant chercher de l'ADN de dinosaure
dinosaur non avien
évidemment oui les dinosaures avant la
météorite avant que avant qu'ils aient
eu le DLC postmétéorite les dinosaures
0.1 la première
version la
beta avant la sortie du DLC c'est ça
avec les plumes c'était la version en
pré en
prévente ça a pas très bien fonctionné
he la météorite donc on on va
s'intéresser en fait à cet objet bizarre
qui est le chiconosaurus qui est
finalement qui qui qui qui qui existe
pas réellement on va dire le
chickenosaurus c'est plus un fantasme
qui a été
survenduou qui a été survendu sur
Internet vous en trouverez pas en train
de de gambader gentiment sur leur deux
petites pattes là ça n'arrivera pas
demain et et et surtout surtout surtout
ce qui ce qu'il y a d'intéressant avec
le chickenosaurus bah c'est c'est quand
même quelque chose qui soulligne bien
justement le lien entre dinosaur et
oiseau et j'espère qu'après la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui vous en serez très
convaincu de ce lien dinosaur oiseau
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de restes en
fait des dinosaures à l'intérieur du du
développement embryonnaire et de la
génétique des oiseaux h et du coup ça ça
a inspiré on va du coup parler de ce que
c'est que le chickenosaurus ça a inspiré
le le paléontologue Jack Horner qui a
proposé ce projet chickenosaurus le
projet puletosaure de de de faire
renaître un dinosaure non avien en
réveillant les gènes dinosauriens à
l'intérieur du génome des oiseaux alors
avant qu'on commence il faut bien dire
un truc tout bête le chickenosaurus n'a
jamais été un projet pour faire
renaître pour faire renaître des
dinosaures à part en faisant des évoluer
des oiseaux c'est vrai que ça va mieux
en le précisant voilà ce qui est
exactement l'opposé de ce que je viens
de dire c'est le chickenosaurus en
réalité c'est juste un un coup de pub
voilà c'est c'est un petit coup
marketing euh qui a été fait par le
paléontologue Jack Horner qui est très
très connu hein paléontologue Jack
Horner mais c'est c'est une vitrine en
fait pour vendre un projet devoo alors
l'evoo qu'est-ce que c'est c'est l'
ution développementale c'est étudier le
développement des animaux modernes pour
mieux comprendre
l'évolution des animaux du passé donc en
d'autres termes dans le cas de
chienosaurus son idée à lui c'était
d'étudier l'embryologie des des oiseaux
modernes notamment du poulet alors
pourquoi le poulet c'est parce que c'est
un c'est un animal modèle en génétique
du développement au même titre que le le
nématode c'estorabditis
éégance la mouche du vinaigre voilà
c'est spécifiquement
voilà et euh et quoi et la souris
blanche Mus musculus voilà oui ça c'est
des trucs qu'on a dans tous les labos
qui sont très répandus donc il est très
facile de se procurer des individus et
en l'occurrence pour étudier le
développement d'un poulet on a besoin
d'œuxf et des œufs bah on en a tout le
tour du ventre en quelque sorte donc
c'est très facile de récupérer des œufs
de poulet le le vertébré le plus le plus
abondant sur terre c'est le poulet grâce
à nous voà entre 20 et 30 milliards on
les a pas tous comptés on n pas on a un
peu la flemme mais bref donc oui c'est
un c'est un animal modèle le poulet pour
l'étude du développement et donc ça ça a
intéressé Jack corner qui a voulu
étudier le développement du poulet pour
mieux comprendre comment les les les les
dinosaures en fait ont évolué en oiseau
et donc pour vendre ce projetl parce que
les projets de recherche il faut les
vendre pour obtenir des financements
c'est dur la vie de chercheur he c'est
dur la vie de chercheur donc pour vendre
ce projet là il a inventé le concept de
chickenosaurus et ça a vachement bien
marché puisque maintenant tout le monde
connait le chickenosaurus tout le monde
connaît le
pouletosaure mais ça n'a jamais été un
projet en fait pour faire renaître un
dinosaure ça c'est c'est un fantasme i
je suis désolé vous en aurez pas un en
animal de compagnie au Noël prochain non
ni au Noël prochain ni dans celui
d'après ni ni probablement jamais et
donc aujourd'hui on va faire un petit
récapépè voilà un récapépè depuis le
début de une petite récapitulation de
tout ce qui a été fait en matière de de
nous amener un pas plus proche de
quelque chose qui pourrait ressembler à
un pouletosaur donc toute la on va faire
on va faire une couverture bon pas
exhaustive non plus mais de de des gros
papiers scientifiques qui ont été sortis
et qui ont attrait de près ou de loin au
pouletosaur vous allez voir qu'il y en a
en fait assez peu où Jack Horner est un
est impliqué curieusement Jack Horner et
ses étudiants se sont surtout intéressés
au développement de la queue alors
depuis le le lancement du projet projet
pouletosaur je crois que c'était en 2012
quelque chose comme ça 2010 ou 2012 je
sais plus ils ont sorti des papiers son
équipe et lui ont sorti des papiers
assez régulièrement on va pas tous les
passer en revue mais c'est surtout à
propos de la queue donc là pour cette
pour aujourd'hui on va en voir deux ce
qui est déjà pas mal euh et on les verra
en dernier euh non pas parce qu'on
l'aime pas mais parce que bah on va
faire de la tête à la queue tout
simplement on fait dans l'ordre on fait
dans l'ordre on va commencer par le bout
du museau du du pouletosaur et on va
finir par le bout de la queue du
pouletosaur euh donc c'est ça l'idée de
de cette petite vidéo c'est de faire un
une grande récapitulation de quel
progrès en fait on a fait en direction
du pouletosur et on va commencer par
l'article du coup qui a probablement
inspiré vraiment le plus directement le
pouetosur c'est un article qui est sorti
dans une très prestigieuse revue qui
s'appelle curent biology euh et qui est
sorti en 2006 et c'est c'est l'article
en fait où ils ont fait repousser des
dents à des poules et voilà c'est c'est
lui poulet à dents trop bien quand les
poulesont les dents c'est lui c'était
c'était là c'était en 2006 he les
poulons ont des dents c'est c'est arrivé
en 2006 voilà donc si vous avez promis
des choses benah tant pis pour vous
c'est déjà arrivé c'est déjà c'est déjà
arrivé donc alors les dents on va se
calmer hein on va se calmer sur la
qualité des dents c'est des petites
denticules c'est pas vraiment des dents
vraies en plus c'est c'est des buddies
he c'est c'est des trucs qu'on même pas
d'maill donc cherchez pas euh donc ce
que c'est ce que vous voyez là en fait
voyez indiqué par les flèches en bleu là
sur le museau de cet embron de poulet
vous voyez des petits buds des petits
buds tout bleus et ça c'est des c'est
vraiment juste des papilles en fait de
d'ambrillon de développement de dents et
qui en fait ne se développe jamais
réellement en fait mais au moins ils ont
réussi à pointer du doigt le gène
responsable de ça ouais qui permet le
début du développement des dents après
il y a plein il y a plein d'autres
réactions en chaîne qui sont nécessaires
notamment pour la production d'maill
donc la différenciation de certains
tissus dans la production de la dent
mais au moins pour arriver à commencer à
produire ses papilles pour faire des
dents bah au moins ils ont réussi à à
activer le gène qui était responsable de
ça et ça c'est quand même assez assez
incroyable mine de rien donc et c'est
c'est intéressant parce que là le pour
le coup c'est des vraiment des gènes
enfin une cascade génétique on va dire
qui est endormie parce qu'ils disent que
c'est bloqué par épigénétique en fait
ouais c'est ça donc l'épigénétique si
vous savez pas alors moi je je suis pas
du tout généticien je bon Sophie est
peut-être un poil plus au fait de la
génétique que moi mais pas de beaucoup
on est pas généticien de toute façon on
n pas généticien donc on va vous mettre
tous les articles en description si vous
avez envie d'aller les lire si vous
voulez en savoir plus si vous voulez
aller les lire allez les voir nous on va
juste parler rapidement de ce que disent
les articles mais c'est vrai que n'étant
pas généticien nos commentaires vont
être assez limités mais voilà là là pour
le coup c'est de l'épigénétique ce qui
veut dire qu'en gros bah c'est comme on
a dit qu' épi c'est sur le dessus
génétique voilà donc c'est par-dessus la
génétique donc c'est pas profondément
engrainé dans le code génétique des des
poulets que le leurs dents doivent
disparaître c'est juste c'est comme si
on avait mis un petit casque au-dessus
pour l'empêcher de c'est comme si le
gène avait un petit casque ou une petite
bulle autour de lui qui l'empêche de
s'exprimer et du coup toute la cascade
génétique qui est censée suivre n'a pas
lieu mais c'est juste une petite bulle
en fait et il suffirait en entre
guillemets il suffirait de il y a qu'
toujours simple ça toujours le comme ça
il suffirait de percer cette petite
bulle donc en l'occurrence si c'est de
l'épigénétique j'imagine que c'est une
métiltilation h euh et donc il suffirait
de percer cette petite bulle pour que
des dents repoussent en l'occurrence ces
poulets ne se développent pas je crois
si si on perce la bubule comme ils l'ont
fait ça marche pas ça crève il me semble
ouais mais en plus ils sont pas allés
jusqu'au bout de la Bible en question vu
que c'est seulement le début des dents
donc de toute façon toute
façon et autre chose super intéressante
dans cet article on constate que c'est
dès le 19e siècle notre jfroid saintyire
national avait déjà remarqué qu'il y
avait des
budies cire donc la la biblio nous dit
c'est référence
32 donc 32 c'était
1821 geoffroid satilire avait déjà
remarqué que il y avait des débuts de de
dents dans les embryons de de poulet
c'est quand même fou ça h voilà sur le
système dentaire des oiseaux c'est donc
depuis 1821 en fait les poules ont des
dents enfin elles ont des dents on sait
qu'il y a un moment où elles peuvent
développer des dents ça veut pas dire
qu'elles en ont mais elles peuvent en
développer c'est ça c'est c'est
différent après l'activer activer le
développement c'est autre chose mais au
moins la possibilité de le faire c'est
déjà c'est déjà connu voilà et tout est
donc enfin à mon avis c'est de là que
c'est parti he tout est donc parti de
cet article là à partir du moment où
vous pouvez faire repousser des dents un
poulet ça été la folie la folie
dinosaure
dinosaure ah c'est vrai qu'il était pas
mal
celuià alors Fast
Forward en
2015 en
2015 avec une autre équipe donc une
équipe qui est dirigée par bartajan
Bullard chercheur britannique qui nous
qui nous a enfin don dont l'équipe nous
a d'ailleurs gratifié de beaucoup
d'articles
pouletosauresque même si justement il
était pas à l'origine de l'idée de
pouletosur ou mais ça ça l'amuse bien
visiblement il il a l'air de
F a fait beaucoup beaucoup des choses
relatives au poulettosaur et dans cet
article de 2015 donc son équipe et
lui-même ont réussi à transformer le bec
d'un poulet en enfin à défusionner en
fait le bec d'un poulet donc un bec
qu'est-ce que c'est finalement en tout
cas dans la mâchoire supérieure un bec
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la fusion des
deux EOS prémaxillaires donc vous avez
deux prémaxillaires ici et quand ils
sont fusionnés et qu'ils n'ont pas de d
alors on appelle ça un
bec nous par exemple nos EOS
prémaxillaires sont fusionnées hein chez
l'humain les EOS prémaxilaires sont
fusionnées mais ils ont des dents donc
on nappelle pas ça un bec bah il y a
aussi le fait que sur le bec vous avez
une enveloe corné de kératine qui est
différente de ce que nous on a parce que
nous du coup on a des dents sur les
oiseaux comme ils ont pas de dents bah
ils ont l'enveloppe de kératine sur le
bec mais je suis sûr qu'ils ont quand
même une enveloppe de kératine dessus
disons que ostéologiquement ce qu'on
appelle un bec c'est vraiment pas de
dent et euh pas de dent et prémaxilaire
fusionné et tant qu'on a pas les deux
ingrédients ensemble en en fait on
naappelle pas ça un bec et le le fait
qu'il y a une couverture cornée ou pas
dessus généralement on évite de le
mentionner puisque ça ça impliquerait du
coup que c'est pas appliquable au
fossiles donc après tu le vois sur les
sur les tortues c'est un bec aussi oui
donc che les tortues ça se voit et il y
a de la corne
dessus mais par exemple je sais pas
est-ce qu'il y a un exemple de truc qui
a des prémaxilaires fusionné mais qu' a
pas de corne dessus cacosurus ilavait
pas cacosurus on suppose qu'il avait
suppose qu'il avait de la corordne mais
du coup on peut pas le savoir puis que
ça se préserve pas donc c'est ça le
problème donc voilà le le bec en tout
cas le bec ostéologique c'est ça c'est
pas de dents et les prémaxilaires les
deux eau prémaxillaires fusionné donc ça
c'est ce qu'on voit chez les oiseaux
vous voyez il y a une seule petite
flèche a une seule pointe vu que les
deux prémaxias sont fusionné et donc ce
qu'ils ont réussi à former avec une en
appliquant une mutation d'un de d'un
certain nombre d'homéogènes donc les
homéogènes c'est les gènes architectes
vous voyez ici col col 1 run X2 et OPN
mais généralement tout ce qui est dans
le développement de toute façon c'est
des gèes architectes oui c'est par
définition c'est par définition et ici
donc sur la la la poupoule mutée la
poule mutante on a deux prémaxillaires
donc les deux prémaxillaires sont
défusionnés et ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant alors il y avait
probablement une couverture cornée mais
ça ils le disent pas et ce qu'il y a de
très intéressant en réalité c'est que
quand on défusionne les deux
prémaxillaires on fait aussi
réapparaître un palais primitif donc ça
c'est LE PALAIS DES OISEAUX quand on
regarde le le crin des oiseaux vu du
dessous vous avez vraiment des toutes
petites baguettes et en fait en faisant
défusionner les prémaxillaires il y a un
il y a un deuxième effet qui se coule il
un effet secondaire qui fait que les les
OP palatins deviennent courts et très
épais enfin épais médiolatéralement et
ça c'est la condition qu'on retrouve
chez les dinosaures en fait donc il y a
un deuxième effet qui se coule qui rend
vraiment le qui transforme complètement
le museau des oiseaux en un museau de
dinosaures en fait mais sans les dents
toujours les d mais par contre mais les
dents on sait comment les enever les
ramener de l'autre côté donc après voilà
vous vous débrouillez mais par contre ce
qu'il disait dans l'article et qui était
intéressant aussi c'est qu'en fait ça
c'est pas la condition
ancestrale le lien entre le palais enfin
ancestral et les prémaxilires fusionnés
disait qu'il y avait certains oiseaux
certains spécimenses qui justement
ancestralement parlant avait soit l'un
soit l'autre mais pas forcément les deux
ensemble et ça c'est intéressant
là par exemple ce qu'on voit c'est
esperornis et donc il a les palintins en
baguette mais apparemment les
prémaxillaires sont fusionnés du coup ça
ça montre ouais que par le passé les
deux caractères étaient pas forcément
dépendants l'un de l'autre mais du coup
chez les oiseaux maintenant maintenant
par contre
salé salé comme la mer comme le beurre
non mais il y a eu recombinaison
certainement à un moment qui fait que
maintenant les deux sont liés d'une
manière ou d'une autre on continue de
reculer un petit peu sur le crâne on
arrive on arrive au cerveau parce que la
différence quand il y a une grosse
différence quand même entre les oiseaux
et les autres reptiles c'est que les
oiseaux là par exemple cette aut ruche
donc ça c'est c'est la boîte crânienne
c'est pas exactement le cerveau mais
c'est un moulage en gros c'est le
moulage naturel que forme la boîte
crânienne autour du cerveau qui reflète
généralement bien la forme du cerveau
lui-même et donc les oiseaux ils ont un
cerveau très rond très volumineux alors
que les autres reptiles comme les
crocodiles eux ils ont un cerveau qui
est plutôt allongé et étroit h et il y a
plein d'études donc qui ont été faites
du du développement du cerveau vous avez
celle-là qui est dans anatomical record
vous voyez une équipe qui inclut
notamment Lauren setmer qui est le
monsieur cerveau des des
arcosaures qui qui qui est vraiment le
pionnier dans la matière de l'étude du
cerveau des arcosaures enfin en tout cas
du du cerveau des arcosaures et surtout
des dinosaures qui a comparé donc les
les trajectoires ontogénétiques
c'est-à-dire du développement
ambryonnaire chez les crocodiles et
enfin les crocodiliens et chez les
autruches et donc ce qu'il a vu en fait
c'est que les les trajectoires
antogénétiques sont assez
originales chez les autruches ça change
quasiment pas donc vous voyez qu'on
démarre à 2 semaines et ici on arrive à
36 mois il y a quasiment rien qui change
par contre chez les crocodiliens là
c'est super intéressant parce que on a
ce cerveau
très allongé très reptilien chez les che
vous voyez quand ils ont plus de 5 ans
le cerveau grandit en continu d'ailleurs
chez les crocodilien comme vous voyez le
c'est pas étonnant vu que la taille de
l'animal grandit avec l'âge aussi il
s'arrête pas en fait de grandir le
crocodil plus il est vieux plus il est
gros alors que l'autruche elle s'arrête
alors que l'aruche voyez ça après ça
plafonne voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est
une c'est ce qu'on appelle une
croissance définie et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle chez les crocodiliens une
croissance indéfinie j'ai généralement
le le premier est attaché aux animaux
qui sont endothermes à sang chaud et le
second est attaché aux animaux
ectotermes donc à sang
froid et et on a aussi cette cette
originalité c'est qu'en fait le cerveau
des crocodiliens très juvénil très très
jeune et plutôt rondouill il est il est
tout rondouillé il est tout mignon
regardez ça contrairement à celui des
adultes qui est très allangé très fin
bah là il est très très rond et très
très large et du coup ça tout se passe
comme si en fait le cerveau des oiseaux
la forme du cerveau des oiseaux était un
sorte de dérivée de la condition
juvénile de ce qu'on voit chez les
crocodiliens et donc ça ça suggère en
fait que il y a eu il y a eu peut-être
peut-être néoténie si vous êtes familier
du concept de néoténie ça ressemble
quand même vachement à ce qu'on appelle
ou une une pédomorphose aussi on appelle
ça des fois donc c'est c'est par exemple
on a ça chez l'être humain vous avez
certainement entendu parler du fait
qu'un le crâne d'un être humain adulte
ressemble au crâne d'un chimpanzé
juvénil notamment les chimpanzés juvénil
ont pas de museau et une grosse boîte
crânienne et des plus grands yeux bah
nous c'est pareil mais sauf que à l'état
adulte on a une forme de crâne de
chimpanzé juvénile ce qui suggère que
durant notre évolution on a on a
acquis un crâne qui ressemble de qui se
ressemblait de plus en plus à celui de
nos juvéniles en fait donc ça c'est un
retard de développement gén généralement
ça se ça se ça se manifeste sous un
forme de retard de sous forme d'un
retard de développement et donc là c'est
aussi un genre de retard de
développement qui aurait eu lieu et qui
aurait permis la conservation en fait de
la de la forme du cerveau juvénil chez
les les adultes oiseau on a aucune idée
du mécanisme génétique derrière donc on
est vraiment très loin d'arriver à
reproduire ça après je sais pas si parce
que là le truc qui montre que le cerveau
donc s'étend encore avec l'âge tu vois
un 1 an après à 3 ans et jusqu'à 5 ans
il de plus en plus allongé mais je pense
que l'allongement du cerveau à mon avis
c'est simplement dû à l'allongement de
la tête aussi parce que le crocodile
quand il est petit effectivement il a
une tête beaucoup plus petite et
beaucoup plus courte proportionnellement
à son corps et quand il est plus grand
bah la tête elle elle s'agrandit elle
s'agrandit et du coup ton cerveau bah il
va s'agrandir avec avec le reste bah là
on a notamment les bulbolfactifs qui qui
sont un problème majeur là dans cette
histoire c'est que les bulbolfactif en
fait chez le crocodile ils sont
pédonculés et donc oui effectivement les
bulbolfactifs doivent suivre
l'allongement de la cavité nasale quoi
avec le nez et la cavité nasale des
crocodiles elle est grande elle est
longuear tout au bout donc bon mais à la
limite on pourrait on pourrait pas
désévoluer un oiseau mais on pourrait
surévoluer un crocodile en le maintenant
en lui injectant des des hormones
d'antiroissance je sais pas
comment euh juste juste dans le cerveau
juste dans le cerveau c'est pas possible
ça mais je pense que c'est c'est dû à la
taille de l'individu juste fa sachant
que les oiseaux arrêtent de grandir au
bout d'un moment bah toute façon ils
arrêtent de se développer alors que la
différence entre le chimpanzé et l'homme
c'est pas pareil vu que le chimpanzé
c'est comme l'homme au bout d'un moment
il atteint un palier il arrête de
grandirou donc je pense qu'il y a il y a
une différence de système en fait entre
ouais y a une question mécanique il y a
de la mécanique derrière il y a pas que
de la génétique en fait il y a une
question mécaniqueouis complèt derrière
et là on a un autre article paru dans la
revue development growth
differentiation encore une équipe
différente à chaque fois c'est des
équipes complètement différentes et eux
ce qu'ils ont étudié c'est l'évolu enfin
c'est eux ils ont pas étudié ils ont
fait une revue de la littérature c'est
c'est un review article c'est une revue
de la littérature où justement il parle
des mécanismes génétiques de la
l'accroissement de la taille du cerveau
chez les oiseaux parce que les oiseaux
euh sont parmi ces vertébrés terrestres
qui ont un très très gros cerveau que
vous pouvez voir ouais un bon cerveau
bien globuleux avec un équivalent en
fait du néocortex ce que vous voyez ici
oui alors le néocortex ouais c'est cette
partie là c'est pas vraiment un
néocortex parce que c'est pas exactement
le même que chez un mésopalium et enfin
c'est le pal bref c'est le oui on
appelle ça un palium voilà c'est et là
c'est un peu différent mais
l'organisation est encore plus
intéressante que celle des mammifère de
mon point de vue parce qu'on est sur des
couches de neurones qui sont encore plus
proches et plus resserré que dans un
cerveau de mammifère en fait il y avait
des articles là-dessus qui est très
intéressant à lire il nous parle du coup
de l'évolution du cerveau et de comment
la partie qui est en vert ici donc le le
néopalium s'agrandit au fur et à mesure
de l'évolution des des des dinosaures
donc là on a les dinosaures les
tyranosauidé oviraptosauidé droméosoidé
trodentidé archéoptérix sachant que tous
ces toutes ces bêtes là en gros ont des
ont des cerveaux qui sont globalement
plus petits que n'importe quel oiseau
moderne à part peut-être certains trop
dentidé et encore ça dépend comment vous
mesurez la taille de ça dépend de en
comparaison à la taille du corps
évidemment oui voilà faut toujours
rapporter à la taille du corp
effectivement sinon un
trexxx voilà il a un plus gros cerveau
que tout le monde mais dans ce caslà la
baleine aussi hein voilà euh et il y a
il y a du coup un tout un passage de cet
articleù on nous parle de de du contrôle
génétique de la de de de ce
développement du cerveau et avec
plusieurs gènes donc qui sont impliqués
dans le développement de ce néopalium et
là où c'est intéressant voilà c'est dans
ce paragraphe là là où c'est intéressant
en fait c'est qu'il soulligne que c'est
très similaire à ce qui se passe chez
les mammifères donc en fait les
l'expansion du néopalium chez les
oiseaux est quand même génétiquement
assez homologue sans être exactement la
même et on peut pas vraiment parler de
de néocortex comme je le disais hein
chez les mamifères on parle on parle de
néocortex mais il y a quand même des
gènes en commun donc toute une liste de
gènes qui sont en commun avec le
développement d'un gros cerveau chez les
mammifères donc finalement même si ça
intéresse pas beaucoup les les gens qui
qui font le le pouletosaur là c'est
surtout des généticiens c'est même pas
tant que ça des paléontologues qui
travaillent là-dessus c'est surtout des
généticiens mais même si c'est pas tant
que ça des paléontologues qui
travaillent dessus en fait il y a il y a
déjà un corpus de littérature tellement
élevé sur l'évolution de la taille du
cerveau bah ne serait-ce que parce que
nous hein c'est les les gens sont très
intéressés à savoir comment les êtres
humains ont acquis un gros cerveau ben
du coup comme il y a un pool génétique
en commun entre l'évolution du gros
cerveau chez les êtres humains et
l'évolution du gros cerveau chez les
oiseaux finalement il y a déjà on a déjà
une masse de connaissance sur le sujet
qui est c'est ça qui qui qui qui est pas
mal et qui ne demande finalement qu'à
être testé sur les oiseaux donc on allez
allez les gars allez le pouletosaur là
c'est le moment regardez le cerveau
regardez le cerveau ouais et il y a un
autre truc avec le cerveau des oiseaux
c'est le ce qu'on appelle le le tectum
optique ce qui correspondrait plus ou
moins chez les mammifères au au
collicues auditif si je ne
m'abuse au collicule visuel pardon donc
les les c'est une partie qui se trouve
dans votre cerveau ça se trouve à
l'arrière à l'arrière et en dessous de
votre
cortex de votre cortex occipital en gros
et c'est c'est des trucs qui sont reliés
à la vision hein bon comme ilindique le
nom logique comme l'indique le nom
tectum optique mais sauf que chez les
oiseaux en fait il y a un truc c'est que
quand vous regardez le le cerveau d'un
oiseau ils sont situés sur les côtés en
fait au lieu d'être situés sur le dessus
du cerveau comme chez tout le monde par
exemple si vous regardez chez un reptile
enfin chez un chez un crocodile par
exemple on les voit ils sont sur le
dessus du cerveau il se situer
évidemment la boîte crâenne donc mais
voilà il se
situerait voilà se situerait au-dessus
ici alors que chez un oiseau ici comme
l'autruche ils sont situés sur le côté
là en fait ils sont poussés
littéralement sur le côté par le le
néocortex enfin le néopalium le
néopalium parce qu'il était d venu
tellement gros qu'il faut bien trouver
un endroit où les mettre exactement et
puis apparemment il y aurait un lien
avec avec le vol aussi parce qu'on
retrouve la même chose chez les ptérosur
alors oui il a un lien avec le vol parce
qu'on considère que ça sert notamment à
s'équilibrer correctement à la vision
pendant le vol à faire en sorte que il y
a tout les organes de l'équilibre qui
interviennent aussi pendant le vol pour
faire en sorte que bah l'oiseau soit pas
complètement déstabilisé par le
changement de perspective et c'est
important sinon faut faire en sorte que
la tête reste droite faut faire en sorte
que le corps bouge pas trop non plus
faut arriver à s'orienter bref c'est
super important la vision pour un oiseau
et donc c'est pour ça que ça c'est aussi
lié à bah B tout ce qui est oreill
interne et cetera et là on a la série de
développement du du du cerveau d'un
poulet B comme j'ai dit he c'est un
animal modèle le poulet c'est pas parce
qu'on c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'on
kiffe les torturer vous les disséquer
mais euh du coup la série de
développement d'un poulet donc de et en
fait quand on remonte le développement
du poulet bah hop on tombe sur un moment
de leur développement où les deux tectum
optique tecta optique euh se touche donc
ils se touch au milieu donc ils sont au
sommet du du cerveau comme dans la
condition
ancestrale la condition qu'on retrouve
chez la chez les dinosaures notamment
archéoptérix je crois est le premier
chez qui les les collicules se séparent
il me semble alors là je saisen je son C
si je si je me rappelle bien et si on
remonte suffisamment loin bah là on a un
cerveau qui est complètement linéaire et
là c'est exactement c'est exactement
Leod mais alors ouais mais là tu es à de
jours alorson en même
temps là c'est c'est crocodiles c'est
poissons c'est c'est standard du base
base de la base c'est la base de la base
mais on est sur un petit nodule neurale
c'est tout ça veut dire que du coup
c'est quand même très très profondément
engrainé dans le développement vous
aurez du mal à revenir en arrière
là-dessus en fait plus ça se développe
tôt et plus c'est profondément engrainé
dans le développement et dans la
génétique quoi h donc ça va là là là
niveau pouletosaur ça ça arrivera
probablement jamais du pouletosaur avec
du gros cerveau on aura pas trop le
choix on aura pas d'autre choix que
d'avoir un pouletosaur à cerveau vre
poulet parce que ça ça a pas l'air
d'être facile à à
rétroingénier ça va pas ça va non pas
rétro inénier mais désévoluer voilà mais
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est système
nerveux de base de toute façon c'est
quand même compliqué entre les couches
de neurones àéagencé enfin je c'est
moins
facile je
wou c'est pas tu tu manques de fois Mo
j'aime pas dawan tu manques de fois de
force peut-être ouais utilise la force
[Rires]
on recule encore un petit peu bah on
arrive sur le sur le corps hein on
arrive sur le corps et quand on arrive
sur le corps de notre poulet on
s'intéresse surtout à ce qui le recouvre
à savoir les plumes et là on a cet
article qui est dont on dont on avait
parlé dans un paléon New qui était sorti
en 2023 donc c'est c'est cette année et
où ils avaient réussi à faire pousser
euh enfin o où ils arrivent à jongler de
manière très fluide entre plumes et
écaille en fait rien qu'en touchant un
gène du développement très connu qui
s'appelle le le gène Sonic le hérisson
Sonic Sonic h son mais ça c'est quelque
chose quiétait connu depuis longtemps en
fa
shshh mais ça c'était quelque chose
qu'on connaissait depuis longtemps parce
que empiriquement ça fait longtemps
qu'on qu'on sait faire des poules qui
ont des des plumes du de la plumopateah
par sélection ouais on a des races de
poules les poules soies par exemple qui
ont des papates toutes plumeuses et en
fait si vous regardez regz bien ces
papates plumeuses elles ont à la fois
des écailles et des plumes qui sortent
de dessous les écailles et c'est
exactement la condition qu'ils ont
reproduit dans cet article là vous avez
effectivement les plumes qui vont sortir
de dessous les écailles de la pâte et
c'est assez amusant h et du coup c'est
la même origine embryonnaire plumé écail
dans ce cas-là ouais ouais parce que moi
c'est ce que j'avais vu du coup là il y
a la placode embryonnaire qui est la
structure de base qui donne à la fois le
la plume les écailles et les poil poil h
les mammifères du coup c'est ça ouais
non c'est exactement la même origine
d'accord ils avaient même réussi à faire
muter des des petits des des lézards des
Beard dragon c'est quoi en français des
birard dragon ou là les pas les pogonas
non si pogon je crois que c'est les
pogonas ouais et du coup ils avaient
réussi à en faire muter donc la la même
mutation qui chez l'humain crée la la
maladie vous avez pas d'ongle pas de
poil et oui et c'est ça
complètementberbe complètement L
et donc en faisant muter le même gène
chez le pogona ça cré un pogona pareil
Liss comme un cul aucune écaille donc
c'était c'était assez c'était assez
assez fou en fait de voir que tout tous
les toutes les fanir ce qu'on appelle
les fanir sont liés en fait
embryologiquement et donc ouais on a là
il jongle assez fluide de façon assez
fluide entre écaille et plume avec
justement là ça se voit très bien les
structures comment les structures
évoluent ils ont vraiment des la très
jolie imagerie qui
documente l'est intermédiaire et qui
démontre du coup que les plumes sont en
fait des écailles très très très modifié
quoi mais ce qui était surtout
intéressant c'est que eux ils ont fait
qu'une seule injection d'une certaine
molécule à un instant donné pendant le
développement et en fait la mutation et
le fait que la plume devienne enfin que
l'caille deviennne une plume a
finalement été stabilisé tout au cours
du développement jusqu'à la fin et n'a
jamais été n'est jamais reparti sur le
stade original qui était juste une
écaille et ce qui est très intéressant
avec cette mutation là c'est que
contrairement au précédents tests de
mutation de plume et cetera parce qu'il
y a plein il y a plein de gènes en fait
qui sont euh mixé dans le développement
des plumes et des écailles qui vont
avoir un effet un peu différent en
l'occurrence là ce qu'ils ont trouvé sur
ce passway là c'est en gros un truc qui
vous permet de faire muter l'écaill de
manière définitive et de faire en sorte
que votre poulet exprime effectivement
des plumes sur ces pattes comme là c'est
c'est montré mais des vraies plumes pas
des trucs un peu désordonnés comme ça
avait été fait préc évidemment avec des
structures qu'on sait pas trop s'il y a
des barbes ou pas ou si c'est juste du
duvet ou une plume de couverture un peu
plus différencié ou quoi là c'est des
plumes qui sont extrêmement bien
différencié et d'ailleurs sur l'image du
milieu là on la voit pas mal il montre
avec la petite flèche celle d'à côté la
petite flèche rouge là VO bien une plume
avec le Rachi central et les barbes sur
les côtés donc on est parti sur une
vraie plume bien symétrique et ça c'est
assez impressionnant mais de toute façon
c'est pas comme si c'était c'est pas
comme si les dinosaures avaient déjà
enfin en tout cas les thopodes avaient
pas déjà des plumes donc en en fait on
n'est pas si intéressé que ça dans dans
un contexte où on veut recréer un
pouletosur de toute façon bah on est
intéressé quand même parce que du coup
ça permet de repartir sur comment est-ce
que les écailles sont sont créés aussi
donc si on peut changer les pluimes en
écailles tu fais l'effet inverse oui ça
tu peux recréer un dinosaure mais
version Jurassic Park c'est ça ultra
rétro exactement en lui pétant les
poignets oui fallir aussi lui péter ses
poignets pour qu'il les tiennent pas oh
FA
un peu de kinétisme peut-être non c'est
ça de chiroprac non pas
ça mais bref ouais donc si vous si vous
êtes tenté par un pouletosor version
Jurassic Park du coup pas un réaliste
non mais du coup alors il faudra faudra
vous pourrez utiliser le gène Sonic le
hérisson le hérisson ils en ont fumé tu
crois ça vous permettra d'avoir un beau
pouletosaur bien rétro rétro vintage
c'est vrai c'est
vrai on recule encore un petit peu on
arrive aux Z loin ouais et on recule
aussi dans le temps parce que là 1940 on
est pas mal aussi hein ouais ben ça m'a
intéressé du coup de parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on sait que les oiseaux de
toute façon ils peuvent avoir des des
griffes puisqu'on a l'ohatsin h le le le
très connu très célèbre oatsin qui quand
il est juvénil a vraiment trois doigts
qui sont quasiment complètement séparés
il y a pas que lui hein et je c'est ce
que dit l'article oui tu spoiles tout
là désolé donc il a trois doigts il a
trois doigts bien séparés dont deux je
crois qui ont des des bonne grosse
griffe et ça lui permet de grimper aux
arbres ouors grosse comparé à la taille
du bestiau et donc il y a ouais je il y
a C article de 1940 qui était déjà une
revue de la littérature à l'époque
disant regardez tous les oiseaux qui ont
des Grif c'est pas forcément une revue
de la littérature c'est lui qui a
identifié plein de trucs et qui a
regardé justement sur des oiseaux des
des des embryillons et des tout jeunes
oiseaux s'il y avait présence de griffe
ou pas donc c'est même pas une revue de
la littérature là c'est juste lui qui a
fait ses études et qui a regardé combien
de fois il pouvait trouver des griffes
dans quelle famille d'oiseaux et dans
quel genre et donc il en a trouvé un
paquet comme vous pouvez le voir là une
bonne liste he d'oiseaux qui ont des
griffes sur les sur les papat sur les P
avant ouais sur les ailes sur les ailes
mais c'est des griffes qui sont là
seulement à l'état embryonnaire ou à
l'état de juvénil c'estàd que quand ils
passent à l'âge adulte généralement ils
les perdent c'est le cas de l'adine oui
et c'est le cas de plein d'autres
oiseaux par chez nous on a le petit
mouse bird qui est un tout petit oiseau
de cette taille là qui a des griffes
aussi pour se tenir pendant la période
de au nid en fait qui lui permet donc
d'éviter de tomber parce que c'est
souvent des oiseaux qui font pas
beaucoup des des nids très très très
très développés pour beaucoup d'entre
eux quand il y a vraiment persistance
des griffes comme ça bah le hadine
typiquement hein c'est un oiseau qui qui
s'accroche aux branches pas exactement
ni chez loadine donc le petit est censé
s'accrocher lu il faut les griffes mais
pour les autres espèces d'oiseau en fait
c'est des griffes qui sont là uniquement
de manière occasionnelle et d'ailleurs
si on regarde ce qu'il a écrit là c'est
que chez beaucoup d'espèces elles sont
là de temps en temps puis d'autres fois
elles sont pas là et c'est très très
très variable on est clairement sur un
caractère qui n'est plus sélectionné
dans beaucoup de familles d'oiseau et
qui du coup a tendance à disparaître de
nos jours ou on appelle ça une
relaxation de la sélection naturelle
quand un caractère est est relictuel et
plus vraiment utile h plus hyper utile
du coup il y a une relâche la sélection
naturelle en fait se détend et le
caractère devient très très variable
voilà euh on a les les autruches aussi
qui ont des des griffes des bonnes
griffes sur les sur les patounes oui
alors là on est plus sur le même le même
problème c'est parce qu'on est sur un
oiseau qui nous vole plus là à
l'occurrence ah oui sur l'autruche parce
que là du coup la la présence de griffe
sur les ailes ça va aussi être quelque
chose qui est important de de de virer
chez l'oiseau adulte parce que là ça va
empêcher le vol correct de l'oiseau
d'accord par comment ça bah sur les
ailes tu as plusieurs types de plumes tu
as les primaires et puis tu as aussi la
luule tout au bout de l'aile qui te
permet de faire les mouvements donc la
Lule c'est les deux trois petites plumes
que vous avez en bout d'aile qui vont
permettre bah c'est notamment vos freins
quand vous êtes un oiseau et ça vous
permettre aussi de changer de direction
c'est extrêmement mobile ça va être
attaché au petits doigts là du Bou et
euh et si vous avez des griffes en plus
de ces plumes en fait bah niveau
aérodynamisme c'est pas top
donc vous allez pas pouvoir changer de
direction aussi facilement donc c'est
pour ça que chez les oiseaux adultes il
est impératif que les oiseaux les
perdent d'accord et c'est pour ça quand
autruches il encore des gris chez les GR
chez les autruches ça va parce qu'il
volent pas donc là il y a pas la même
sélection qui s'opère donc là il y a un
article plus récent et qui parle
d'embryologie où là on voit bien
justement chez l'embryon de P on voit
bien les griffes qui sont maintenues
c'est ça et donc le l'embron de poulet
ici qui ressemble beaucoup à donc ça
c'est Lezine je crois non c'est non il
c'est quoi si c'est le c'est le c'est
pas un oadine c'est opyocomus ophyocomus
non c'est peut-être l'adine c'est
l'azine bref là vous avez une main de
dinosaure quoi en gros une main de de
maniraptorien et là vous avez une main
enfin une aile du coup de poulet mais
embryologique ouais St emonnaire c'est
un embryonnaire où on voit les les
phalanches sont très très bien séparé et
où on voit notamment les griffes bien
pointu qui vont ensuite fusionner avec
le reste de la main pour former cette
île cette cette aile pardon bien rigide
ouais qui va être très importante au vol
ça ça va être maintenu principalement
chez les oiseaux qui volent ou qui
nagent d'ailleurs parce que chez les
manchau et tout ça c'est la même chose
que vous allez retrouver aussi parce que
c'est pareil c'est extrêmement important
pour la nage mais par contre chez les
oiseaux comme l'utruche bah c'est pas
extrêmement nécessaire vu qu'il s'en
servent uniquement pour le display h et
et c'est
tout donc bah au final pas vraiment
besoin d'aérodynamisme dans ces cas-là
pour pour le poletosaur par contre ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant article de 2022
paru dans Nature cette fois donc là on
revient à des revues
prestigieuses l'équipe donc c'est
l'équipe de Bulard le retour bajan Buard
c'est pour ça que c'est dans natureure
faut faire un peu de
pub qui a remarqué en fait que dans le
développement des embryons de poulet et
ben il y avait un stade en fait alors ça
c'est le croco fa que tu descende sur le
pou vous REC si vous remontez assez loin
dans l'embryologie du poulet en fait
vous allez trouver un stade où où le
bassin a deux branches donc une branche
qui s'appelle le pubis et une branche
qui s'appelle lischum bon ça jusque- là
tout va bien c'est normal sauf que le
pubis est orienté vers l'avant et
l'ischium vers l'arrière exactement
comme chez les crocodiles les premiers
arcosores les dinosaures sorisquiens
dont les théropodes c'est-à-dire les
ancêtres des oiseaux font partie donc en
fait ils ont découvert que chez tout
premier stade de l'embryogénèse voyez à
5 jours 5 ou 6 jours h les poulets ont à
bassin sorisquien et que c'est pendant
l'embryogenèse donc arrivé à 6 jours
puis là vous avez 6 6 jours et demi puis
euh toujours à 6 jours et demi puis 7
jours voilà 7 jours ça ça pass ça se
passe vraiment ça se passe vraiment très
très très très vite hein ouais là là
faut pas clleiner des
yeux faut pas cliner des yeux et puis
faut augmenter le contraste à mort aussi
hein là je ils ont dû utiliser un
produit de contraste assez euh ben si tu
regardes bien en fait c'est le moment où
les les
petites les les petites vertèbres vont
commencer à se différencier que là
l'iscium euh le pibis et l'ilion
prennent une forme un peu différente
ouais et et c'est seulement à partir de
ce moment-là que là hop ça part vers
l'arrière et par contre c'est pas sur du
poulet c'est sur de la caille qu'ils ont
fait ah oui la caille japonaise les
petits trucs là tu sais ah oui la caille
japonaise h HM ils ont trahé le pouet
c'est c'est la caillosor c'est la
caillosor pour cell la kayokaine
voilà et alors ouais est-ce qui ce qui
donc on voit en fait c'est encore une
fois c'est vraiment là c'est un cas
typique de l'ontogénèse récapitulant la
la phyogénèse du coup avec le
développement du poulet qui démarre en
soriskien qui finit
en oiseau on va pas dire ornitiskskien
parce que ornitisquen c'est c'est les
dinosauresiv qui ont pas laissé de
descendant mais mais bon c'est c'est
plus ou moins là on va reprendre Richard
den les avis
pelviens donc le le le pubis orienté
vers l'arrière et collé à lisquion donc
ce qu'on retrouve chez les oiseaux
adultes modernes h et avec toutes les
étapes intermédiaires entre le le bassin
à deux branches et les deux branches qui
se rapproche donc les teréropodes les
Maniraptoriens notamment les les
Maniraptoriens les plus dérivés comme
chez archéoptérique et les drroméosaur
vous avez un pubis qui est presque
vertical qui a tellement migré vers
l'arrière qui est presque vertical sous
le bassin ça c'est vraiment l'identité
de ces deux états est absolument
incroyable le enfin l'hom logie C de ces
deux trucs c'est c'est ouf c'est là que
tu te rends compte que le développement
obligatoirement bah comme partout tu es
obligé de faire avec ce qu'il y avait
avant donc bah tu commences avec l'État
ancestral et puis tu finis avec ce que
tu as réussi à développer derrière c'est
ça c'est un état ça marche pas avec tous
les trucs ça marche pas avec tous les
trucs mais en l'occurrence dans ce
cas-là ça marche bien h un état de
caractère oui ça se développe par-dessus
un autre état de caractère qui était
déjà viable avant lui en fait donc tu
peux pas écraser comme ça
eu et d'histoire c'est ça là les les les
les arcosoriformes là qui ont évolué en
premier ce bassin là on est au Trias euh
et avant eux le bassin avait cette
tronche là depuis bah depuis que le
bassin était apparu quoi c'est-à-dire au
Dévonien donc tu as plus de tu as 200
millions d'années de bassin avec un
pubis vers l'avant et un isquion vers
l'arrière qu'il faut écraser pour en
arriver là en fait et donc oui c'est
c'est même étonnant d'ailleurs qu'ils y
soient aussi bien arrivés parce que
tu noteras aussi que dans le nouveau
bassin des oiseaux vous avez des
vertèbres fusionnées donc qui vont aussi
s'ajouter à ça euh à la formation du
bassin original qui n'avait pas ces
vertèbres fusionnées derrière qui vont
servir après au vol donc c'est à partir
de ça qu'on va avoir droit à du vol
battu B c'est le sasacrome c'est ça non
c'est la formation du sasacrome avec la
fusion avec le bassin oui ouais donc si
on arrive à identifier les gènes qui
sont attachés à ça ce qui n'est pas le
cas je crois dans ce dans cet article
ils ont juste repérer le la morphologie
mais ils ont pas repéré les gènes qui en
sont responsables mais si on arrive à
repérer les gènes on pourra refaire un
bassin un bassin de dinosaures à nos
oiseaux en tout cas un bassin de
sorisquien voilà donc de thopode au
final et ça c'est quand même ce serait
quand même fou alors je pense pas que ce
sera viable ça m'a l'air d'être une
mutationas vu comme je disais faut pas
faut tellement pas cligner des yeux pour
arriver à la retrouver que que là ouais
c'est ça ça a l'air d'être lié à une
telle quantité d'autres caractères mais
comme tu disais là la fusion des des
vertèbres au bassin mais ça aussi c'est
quelque chose que tu veux avoir des
vertèbres non fusionnés au bassin si tu
veux recréer entre guillemets un
dinosaure ça le problème c'est que dès
que tu touches à tout ce qui est
neurologie de toute façon c'est fort
probable que ce soit pas viable derrière
parce que là les vertèbres
ouais c'est le problème de toutes ces
mutations le problème c'est qu'avec
l'mitation tu as toujours le le problème
de la potropie c'està-dire que le un
gène N n pas égal à un caractère en fait
ou une protéine un gène en fonction de
comment il va être replié pendant la
traduction ou en fonction de de ce qui
va se trouver tout juste à côté ou en
fonction de quand il s'exprime ou en
fonction de dans quelle cellule il
s'exprime un gène ne va pas exprimer un
caractère il va il va y avoir un gène et
plusieurs caractères attachés à un seul
gène c'est ce qu'on appelle de la
pléotropie enfin entre autres il y a le
phénomène de la pléotropie mais il y en
a plein d'autres et c'est si vous vous
rappelez les cauchemars de de SVT les
introns et les exons oui l'activation
des gênnes ou pas ça tout ça donc ouais
là et c'est ça le problème en fait c'est
que dès que vous touchez un gène vous
touchez pas un caractère c'estàd qu'il
suffit pas de désévoluer un gène pour
désévoluer le corps si vous désévoluez
un gène vous allez un merdier en
c'est une réaction en chaîne en fait qui
va se produire pas juste un c'est pour
ça que beaucoup de ces TR c'est pas un
interrupteur c'est pas juste un
interrupteur faut imaginer dans ce cas
c'est c'est plus qu'un interrupteur ce
serait genre un un espèce de de fusil à
pompe c'estàdire que vous appuyez d'un
côté et ça fait 1000 trous dans l'autre
bout ouais la grenaille c'est de la
grenaille oui c'est ça donc ouais mais
là celui-là ça c'était quand même un des
articles qui m'a le
plus qui m'a le plus impressionné parce
que vraiment on a une une une identité
entre l'État entre l'ontogénie et la
phyogénie qui est
juste c'est possible ça je sais plus
quel terme ils utilisent mais il y a un
terme pour ça ça trou le cul je crois
que c'est ça qui
dit non c'est pas ça on était donc au
niveau du bassin on va descendre dans
les gibols maintenant dans les gibols
avec avec cet article donc dans un
journal qu'on a déjà vu hein c'est
comment il s'appelle celui sur le
développement et évolution non c'est
évolution ça rien à voir avec le
développement mais on a déjà vu on a
déjà vu cette mise en page précédemment
euh une équipe ah tiens complètement
différente euh que jingm au conard on a
déjà vu son nom tout à l'heure je sais
plus dans quel article mais bref la la
fusion du tibia et de la fibula pour
former le le tibiotars le fameux le
fameux tibiotars c'est un une
caractéristique des oiseaux le tibiotars
qui donc renforce renforce la Gibo à
l'atterrissage et donc ils ont trouvé un
moyen génétique c'est ça de de faire
repousser un tibio enfin de du coup de
reséparer le tibia du de la fibu enfin
la fibula pardon du du tibia donc le le
péronais en français euh ils ont
trouvver un moyen de reséparer le le le
perérronet du du
tibia qui était fusionné alors il est
partiellement fusionné chez archéoptérix
je crois qu'il y a une une belle
philogénie il est partiellement fusionné
chez archéoptérix il me semble enfin ils
sont partiellement
fusionnés et après le le on voit le
tibia on voit le la fibula pardon
commencer à à régresser en fait jusqu'à
ce qu'elle soit complètement
indiscernable chez les oiseaux modernes
h et bah vas-y commence bah ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait ils ont ils
ont trouvé que si jamais on gardait la
la fibula comme elle est complètement
enfin complète entière au lieu de
l'avoir régressé comme ça le bon du coup
l'os d'à côté il deviit un peu plus
petit beaucoup moins allongé du coup et
surtout il a une espèce de masse au
centre qu'on voit bien sur cette sur
cette image là qui fait qu'en fait son
développement est un peu un peu bizarre
avec une espèce de boule au centre et
donc ça fonctionne beaucoup moins bien
donc ce qui les hypothèses qui qu'ils
émettaient dans l'article là on voit
bien le vois bien là on voit bien le
problème là donc ça c'est la condition
contrôle donc contrôle ça veut dire pas
de mutation ça c'est un crocodile ça
c'est un oiseau je crois c'est ça ouais
et là on a la condition mutante donc le
mutant C
hh27 ouais bon c'est le gène c'est le
c'est son petit nom euh et quand on mute
ce gène on a effectivement une une
séparation nette entre tibia et fibula
mais surtout on a la fibula qui continue
de se développer et qui va faire une
hypophyse donc les hypophyses c'est les
les bouts des nonos donc normalement il
y en a une sur le le tibiotaredans sur
la fibula vous avez une une hypophy qui
va se développer en haut mais il y en
aura pas en bas si vous regardez le l'os
contrôle là sur le côté on voit bien il
y en a une en haut qui va donc plus ou
moins souder avec le tibia mais vous en
avez avait pas en bas et du coup son
développement en fait s'arrête à ce
niveau-là il n'y en aura pas qui se
développera par contre si vous le faites
se développer et qu'effectivement il va
jusqu'en bas et vous voyez qu'il y a une
hypophyse qui s'est développée jusqu'en
bas qui est colorée en bleu là sur ce
petit os c'est l'hypophyse c'est le
cartilage qui est coloré en bleu et ben
du coup l'os d'à côté le tibia ne se
développe pas bien et est beaucoup plus
restreint en taille donc ça expliquerait
aussi pas mal l'allongement de la taille
du tibiotars chez les oiseaux c'est tout
se passe comme si en fait si le le le
péronis donc la fibula touche le bout du
tibia en fait il elle dit au tibia stop
c'esttoi le
chatarrête du coup le il fait quoi quoi
il continue de pousser mais il arrive
plus à pousser en fait et du coup il se
tort voà il continue de grandir mais
comme il arrive plus à grandir en
hauteur bah
il il se tort comme ça c'est ça vous
avez la même chose sur l'autre à côté
pareil hein avec une petite torsion
voilà ici voilà et puis bon l'autre qui
est bien séparé sur le côté et du coup
on voit bien la différence entre les
deux HM donc là on pourrait mais ça
ferait des des oiseau qui auraiit des
légers handicap moteurs quand même ça
ferait un chickenosaurus avec un léger
handicap moteur faut imaginer des papat
beaucoup plus courte en fait et euh et
et un peu recourbé comme s'il avait
monté à cheval toute sa vie mais ceci
dit euh justement que les les dinosaures
avaient des des des membres plus
robustes et que du coup c'est peut-être
cohérent du coup bah oui plus court et
plus robuste plus court et plus robuste
effectivement mais par contre ils sont
pas il y a pas d'angle au milieu
normalement c'est juste que du coup
c'est une conséquence derrière comme
comme on a dit tout à l'heure il y a
plusieurs gènes qui sont impliqués
là-dedans vous pouvez pas juste en
désactiver un espérer que ça revienne
complètement l'ét ancestral ça marche
pas ça n'arrivera jamais voilà il y a
d'autres choses en en
cours donc c'était un article
intéressant aussi il y a beaucoup
d'autres choses làdedans qui sont il y a
beaucoup d'hypothèses qui sont posées il
il y a beaucoup de trucs et ça c'est
aussi sorti cette année d'ailleurs ça
vient de sortir ce mois-ci le comme le
mois où on parle non non c'est c'est
sorti en 2016 pardon c'est pas le même
article je pense à un autre article mais
mais en tout ça c'est sorti en 2016 bon
ça ça reste relativement récent et
c'était moi j'ai trouvé intéressant mais
il y a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations là-dedans faut faut
vraiment aller le lire pour bien
comprendre tout ce qu'ils disent parce
qu'il y a vraiment plein plein de trucs
que soit au niveau des gènes ils ont
fait aussi une exp dans cet article là
où ils font pas avec des gènes mais ils
vont séparer manuellement le tibia de la
fibula à côté avec genre une couche de
truc entre alors je sais plus ce qu'ils
ont mis entre mais en gros ils séparent
les deux et là tu as effectivement le
même résultat avec la fibula qui se
sépare et qui se vraiment est
différencié du tibia et qui du coup se
développe différemment et ce qui te
montre qu'en fait le développement des
deux est lié
h ça montre que si on les sépare
manuellement ça ça les sépare mais non
ça veut dire mais non la fibula se
développe
comme en fait en fait c'est le tibia qui
dit à la fibula maattant t'arrête c'est
ça il y a y a donc il y a une
communication entre les deux c'est que
si la fibula touche le tibia par en bas
enfin distalement du coup ça dit au
tibia c'est toi le chat
voilà mais si le touche par en haut par
contre c'est le tibia qui dit à la
fibul ça suffit et parce qu'en fait
sinon il se rendent compte aussi que si
jamais tu gardes cette deuxième épiphy
en dessous c'est elle qui va parasiter
un peu le développement du tibia au
milieu et qui va former cette espèce de
boule de nonos au milieu du TIG
c'est intéressant h ah ouais c'est donc
il y a plein de trucs dans cet article
c'est super intéressant à l ça montre
aussi que cette seule mutation est
définitivement pas la seule il y a tout
un cocktail de c'est c'est ce qu'
explique à la fin de signaux qui qui
sont échangés par les deux EOS enfin par
les cellules des deux EOS ouais c'est
fou il y a plein de régulations contre
régulation machin chose c'est super
intéressant bon faut un petit peu de
génétique
là-dedans un petit peu d'embryologie
mais moi j'ai trouvé ça très très
intéressant puis on arrive à la papate
donc à la papate ce qui va évidemment la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
qu'on pourra recréer un raptor quoi
qu'on peut recréer un raptor avec sa sa
griffe rétractable sur le pied
rétractable rétractile rétract
rétractopel c'est l'échat qu'on é
rétractable rétractable rétractile
rétractile toussable oui soulevable
relevable relevable et la questionah la
question c'est qu'en fait la réponse
c'est qu'on en a pas besoin puisqu'on a
déjà les Cariamas on a les kiamas
regardez les beaux carariam d'Amérique
du Sud plus proche parents d'ailleurs
des des Forus racidés oui les oiseaux
terreur et c'est c'est donc kariama ont
déjà une le doigt numéro 2 de du pied
qui a une grosse griffe rétractile il y
a une photo là qui est très jolie qui le
montre très très bien elle est où cette
photo c'est une PR ouais c'est celle-là
où on voit bien là regardez là comment
il tient ses griffes là c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est ouais c'est vir
de J part quoi c'est complètement ça
c'est complètement ça il y a dans une
moindre mesure parce que c'est pas aussi
la griffe est parourbée comme ça mais
dans une moindre mesure il y a le casoir
aussi qui a ça ouais alors c'est très
différent chez le casoir par contre
parce que comme tu dis la Griff est
parcberé et la manière dont le doigt est
tenu aussi chez le casoir c'est vraiment
à plat le doigt là on a l'impression
qu'il est vraiment relevé un petit peu
faut se dire que la griffe aussi ça fait
partie de du reste avec les eos et tout
ça donc normalement tuas uneange dedans
en fait voilà donc voilà le le doigt est
effectivement recourbé comme ça alors
que chez le casoir il est bien droit et
la griffe alors la griffe est beaucoup
plus longue par contre mais elle est
toute plate et elle est quasiment collée
au sol ouais et ça c'est et c'est quand
même super cool de savoir quand même
qu'on a un équivalent écologique
finalement au au droméosaur parce que ça
permet aussi d'étudier du du coup
comment ils s'en servent et en
l'occurrence ils s'en servent pour
pointer les serpents c'est ça pas
forcément ils s'en servent pour tenir
leur nourriture en fait d'accord donc il
s'en serent un peu comme comme le frein
un aigle parce qu'on a aussi pareil sur
le même type alors je regardais ça tout
à l'heure et je je regardais mais en
fait la la la la forme de la griffe et
la forme des trucs c'est effectivement
la même forme qu'on a sur les seres d'un
aigle parce que pareil ça change la
griffe non sur ouais là du coup ils ont
que sur un doigt sur les Aigles il non
sur T les doigts mais la la forme de la
griffe c'est que tu es obligé tenir ton
doigt comme ça parce que de toute façon
il tiendra pas sur l'air trop recourbé
pour pour être posé droite sur le sol et
donc sur les Aigles c'est pareil ils
utilisent leur serre on appelle ça des
seres du coup pour tenir la proie
pendant qu'il la dépiotent qu'il la Mang
et ils s'en servent aussi pour pour
attraper des trucs pour tenir des
machins sur le sol en fonction de ce
qu'ils utilisent mais par contre ils
utilisent leur bec ces animaux là pour
tuer leur proie quand ils en ont besoin
et ils la tapent sur le sol comme ça un
peu comme le frerait un par exemple
ouais donc ce que gr il dit dans
Jurassic Park c'est des conneries il il
ne lacère pas sa victime avec sa griffe
non il la sert pas il la tient juste en
fait la PR c'est que toute façon quand
on regarde les griffes de Raptor elles
n'ont pas de lame il y a pas de lame sur
une griffe de Raptor c'est c'est juste
il y a recourbé avec au bout c'est juste
fait pour tenir et pour éviter que parce
que généralement c'est comme une ser
d'igle du coup fonctionnellement ça
marche fctionnellement c'est comme une
serre d'igle ou de rapace nocturnne type
hibou ce genre de choses qui
effectivement vont et et là tu vois bien
parce que AC les doigts très courts
comme ça tu as beaucoup de puissance
dans le doigt lui-même qui te permet
vraiment de maintenir un truc qui est en
train de se débattre donc faut faut
imaginer que ça ça sert à maintenir une
proie qui est pas totalement morte
pendant que l'oiseau s'amuse à déchirer
ses entrailles et donc on avait ça aussi
chez les Forus racidé comme des
empreintes l'ont démontré juste il y a
quelques semaines et euh par contre on a
aucune idée de des mécanisme génétique
de ça de ce qui se passe derrière ça
donc c'est juste on sait que ça existe
encore on sait que ça existe encore
comme morphologie ça existe encore chez
les oiseaux modernes donc peut-être que
plutôt que de partir d'un poulet on
devrait partir d'un cariama alors la
ouais la différence c'est que ceux-l il
volent ceuxl il volent ouais les Forus
racidés il volaient pas oui bah mais si
on pouvait partir d'un Forus racidé ce
serait plus simple
effectivement c'est un peu le même
problème qu'on a avec les dinosaures si
tu veux ah bon les oiseaux terreur je
passais pas pourtant ils avaient le DLC
ils avaient le DLC post météorite tu
vois y en avait un deuxième un deè DLC
ben non ils ont pas ils ont pas résisté
au DLC grand interchange biotique
américain ils ont ils av ils avaient pas
ce DLC là et du coup ils ont bugé ils
ont il le programme a craché au grand
interchange il y a de million d'anné
c'est terrible c'est
terrible mais c'est c'est des oiseaux
qui sont très intéressants en tout cas
mais il y a il y a plus que deux espèces
de nos jours faut savoir que la majeure
partie de leur famille s'est éteintte du
coup oui bah surtout si tu ajoutes les
Forus racidés oui ça ça bah il y a pas
que mais ça ça défonce encore plus la
diversité
de le leur
ligné la queue passons à la queue et
donc là maintenant Jack Horner Jack
Horner qui est là enfin du coup son vrai
nom c'est John R Horner bon les gens
l'appellent Jack Horner mais pourquoi il
l'appelle Jack et pourquoi pas non mais
c une question honnête je je sais pas je
sais pas il av envie de s'appel Jack
comme je disais depuis le début du du
pouletosaur dans les au début des années
2000 ils ont sorti des articles très
régulièrement on va en faire que deux
euh ça c'est le plus récent euh mais et
là il y a un des plus anciens justement
au tout début du projet pouletosaur en
2014 en fait ils avaient fait une grande
revue de la littérature sur l'évolution
de la queue et donc comment la la queue
des dinosaures qui est très allongé avec
plein de vertèbres est devenue la queue
des oiseaux qui est très très courte et
forme un croupion donc un pigosyle enfin
le croupion c'est la structure en
général avec la chair et le et le l'os à
l'intérieur qui est l'équivalent de
notre coxis à nous en fait c'est le
pigostyle donc c'est la fusion de d'une
d'un grand nombre pas d'un grand nombre
de certaines vertèbres de de la queue
quoi et ce l'origine de ce spigostyle
bah c'est évidemment une une transition
importante dans l'origine des oiseaux HM
et et donc ils avaient fait cette dans
la revue Evo devo he évolution
développementale son équipe vous voyez
avait fait une une grande revue de la
littérature sur l'évolution et la
l'évolution et le développement de la de
la queue en pigosyle chez les chez les
oiseaux et chez les dinosaures concluant
dans cette revue qui avait quand même
pas moins de 23 mutations donc j'imagine
23 plus de 23 gènes mais tu vas me le
confirmer qui
sont qui sont impliqués en fait dans la
disparition de la queue et sa
transformation en pigostyle voilà plutôt
que de faire des gestes avec les mains
j'aurais dû montrer cette cette image ça
parle beaucoup
plus donc en plus plus là on voit bien
les les vertèbres du bout de la queue
qui étaient
déjà plus ou moins fusionné chez les
Maniraptoriens donc chez les
droméosaures et archéoptérix par exemple
par par des tendons ussifiés et qui donc
s raccourci c'est Rabou gris jusqu'à
devenir le PIG hosyle qu'on voit chez
les oiseaux modernes du coup il y a
plusieurs phénomènes parce qu'il y a à
la fois une réduction du nombre de
vertèbres parce que là vous voyez ch il
y en a quand même un paquet et chez
Galus donc la poule vous en avez bah
quatre
5 avant le le pigocy lui-même et puis le
pigosy lui-même est formé de TR quatre
vertèbres il me semble donc en fait si
vous comptez les vertèbres choptérix il
en a vachement plus que ça et donc il y
a déjà une réduction du nombre de
vertèbres et en plus derrière il y a une
ossification et une jonction entre les
dernières vertèbres pour former le
pigostyle qui est cette structure
osseuse à la fin de la queue mais du
coup il y a plein de phénomènes plein de
de de passways comme les appels qui sont
importants dans l'formation de tout ça
alors là c'est là où il explique la
formation des somites les somites c'est
les petits trucs qui vont notamment
permettre de de segmenter votre corps en
différents segments pendant
l'embryogeenèse qui permettent de savoir
combien vous allez avoir de vertèbres où
sont vos bras où sont vos jambes sur
quelle paire de vertèbres ça ça va
s'attacher et cetera donc ça c'est les
somites et ils expliquent là-dedans que
justement la formation des somites va
conduire à la formation des vertèbres et
derrière à la longueur de la queue aussi
h parce que en plus dans le
développement oui
on tous les tous les animaux
puricellulaires à part les à part les
knidaires et les éponges en gros sont
des animaux segmenté donc on est juste
une répétition du même segment plusieurs
fois et chaque segment après se
spécialise plus ou moins et chez les
vertébrés ça se voit encore justement
dans dans les vertèbres et finalement la
transformation de la queue en pigosyle
ce n'est jamais que une partie des
segments qui se spécialise pour former
autre chose quoi ou une réduction de du
nombre de segments qui sont fabriqués
pendant l'emri jeunèe et là ça c'est ce
qu'ils expliquent c'est des systèmes de
régulation ça à partir de de diverses
molécules qui vont réguler qui vont
implémenter la formation de somit ou au
contraire l'arrêt de la formation des
somites ce qui est très marrant c'est
qu'ils utilisent de un acide que vous
connais c'est peut-être qui est dérivé
de la vitamine A qui est très très très
envoque dans les crèmes antiage
dernièrement qui est l'acide
rétinoïque rétinol n'est-ce pas et qui
en fait sert beaucoup dans le développp
pour développer pas mal de choses que
soit au niveau neurologique dans le
cerveau mais aussi dans la formation des
somites et et qui est très très très
utilisé et qu'on dont on cherche les
applications d'ailleurs de nos jours
pour toutes les les lésions cutanées ou
pour la réparation bah de la de notre
colonne vertébrale ou des nerfs enfin
bref des problèmes neurologiques qu'on
pourrait avoir ouais parce que fautut tu
dis cutané et nerveux mais parce que la
peau et les Ners c'est la même origine
embryologique oui c'est vrai j'ai pas
précisé c'est pour ça que ça marche sur
les deux ça marche sur les deux ouais et
il y a pas mal d'études qui ont été fait
du coup sur le l'embryogénèse des souris
parce que on est intéressé de savoir
comment notre cxis à nous s'est formé en
fait c'est plus ou moins les mêmes
j'imagine c'est plus ou moins les mêmes
oui les mêmes cheminement embryologique
qui REC conduisent à la formation du
pigostil à la formation du du ce qui
c'est ce qui montre là effectivement
c'est basé sur ce qu'on appelle un
ensemble de gènes Ox qui sont des gènes
du développement donc là c'est ce qui
vous montre là il y a je sais pas
lesquels c'est ex exactement mais en
gros les gèes Hox c'est ce qui vous
permet d'avoir toutes ces somites qui
vont se différencier et plus tard la
différenciation des somites en fonction
de leur antériorité ou de leur
postériorité dans l'animal en lui-même
et en fonction de leur position elles
vont devenir quelque chose ou quelque
chose d'autre et c'est super intéressant
à étudier la biologie du développement
c'est un peu compliqué mais là en
l'occurrence on vous montre une souris
avec les somites qui se développent
correctement et une souris avec des
gènes Ox qui sont pas exprimés
correctement là une trop grande
expression d'un certain gène
homéogènex c'est le gradient
d'expression du de de l'homéogène ça
marche plus c'est le gradient
d'expression donc de l'acide rétinoï ou
du rétinol là rtinoï acide voilà qui qui
se qui s'exprime trop à cause du gène Ox
qui s'est un peu trop exprimé du coup
pour produire cet acide là et qui va
encourager en quelque sorte la formation
d'une queue plus réduite et d'un
pigostier donc c'est c'est super
intéressant donc tout ça c'est des des
mécanismes d'embryogenèse qui sont
intéressant à étudier là vous voyez le
le développement d'une d'une queue chez
alors tout à fait normal là pour le coup
chez un embryon de de poulet avec le
sasychrome là qu'on voit bien d' bien
illustré ici voà donc là ça c'était
juste la revue de la littérature pour ce
qui était connu en 2014 et donc il y a
eu là on va faire Fast
Forward vers leur dernier article qui
est sorti en 2022 ou 2023 je me rappelle
plus exactement dans la revue très
prestigieuse je crois c'est 2023 PNAS je
men rappelle en avoir parlé il y a pas
longtemps
dans 2023
donc 2023 et donc dans cette revue PNAS
très prestigieuse la même équipe même je
crois que c'est Diana Rachid ça doit
être l'étudiante de de Jack Horner je
pense la même équipe donc nous annoncit
qu'en fait ils ont trouvé un moyen
maintenant de transformer un pig hosyle
en que donc là ils ont et ce moyen en
fait c'est ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est que c'est pas une mutation
génétique c'est juste l'inje
d'anti-inflammatoire parce que en fait
ils ont découvert qu'en injectant un
anti-inflammatoire à un moment du
développement qu'ils expliquent
exactement quand chez le les embryons de
d'oiseau en fait et en injectant cette
anti-inflammatoire et ben vous empêchez
les vertèbres de se souder et du coup
c'est une c'est une forme d'inflammation
contrôlée qui provoque au moins en
partie la la fusion des vertèbres donc
c'est leur conclusion ici que j'ai que
j'ai mis en en jaune si vous souhaitez
la lire vous pouvez je vous la laisse à
l'écran mais ouais c'est c'est
intéressant du coup de de de constater
que ouais de que déjà l'inflammation est
un
phénomène du développement embryonnaire
chez les vertébrés ce qui est quand même
assez c'est assezou dingue quand vous y
pensez déjà avant de naître vous êtes
déjà sujet à
l'inflammation la douleur douleur la
douleur la douleur est imprimée en vous
la douleur fait partie de toi c'est déjà
là voilà la vie c'est de la douleur
absolument c'est incroyable et donc et
et la douleur fait partie de votre
développement et donc si vous êtes un
oiseau vous avez mal au cul et c'est
pour ça que vous avez un un
pigosy résumé comme ça c'est une petite
saveur un peu
parti si tuas mal à un cul ben jeis que
tu as un
picyle un Coxy ça marche aussi pour nous
est-ce que ça marche pour nous c'est
c'est la première question que qu'on
peut se poser est-ce que le cxis aussi
c'est dû à une inflammation du
inflammation du cul parce que là donc
pareil ça ça une régulation sur son jog
évidemment l'inflammation hein qui
d'autre qui
d'autreautre ça pique les hisson vous l'
déjà dit voilà tout est lié tout est lié
tout est lié mais mais du coup en fait
là ce qu'ils ont montré c'est que
normalement là la photocont contrôle qui
est le pigocile normal ce qui va passer
c'est que lors de la formation de la
queue donc vous avez les vertèbles qui
vont se former normalement et puis après
vous avez une inflammation contrôlée en
quelque sorte qui va se déclenché à
l'endroitù vous auriez normalement avoir
des disques intervertébraux qui sont
donc du cartilage et à cet endroit-là
vous allez avoir en fait une destruction
puis une reconstruction des cellules via
une sorte de calus osseux qui va se
faire par-dessus et qui va donc former
ce petit pigosyle qui va être en fait un
un gros calus osseux au final la calus
c'est du tissu cicatriciel haseux voilà
donc c'est comme ça qu'ils ont pu
définir que ça bah ça avait été à cause
d'une inflammation parce que vous avez
le tissu qui est exactement pareil que
du tissu cicatriciel normal avec une
destruction de cellules à l'intérieur
qui montre très bien dans dans les coup
pistologiques qu'ils ont fait derrière
donc pareil article très intéressant
ouais
je il y a du génie là pour arriver à
cette conclusion là il y a génie
intéressant et d'ailleurs ça part aussi
sur la la question de à quoi ça sert un
pigosy parce que c'est aussi une très
bonne question et puis est-ce que du
coup les autres zones dans le corps de
l'oiseau qui sont des endroits fusionnés
sont aussi issus de la même la même
inflammation et le même type de réaction
parce que vousz pas que ça dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure typotarar méatars
c'est aussi la fusion bah des tars et
des métatars puis vous avez le bassin et
il y a le bassin avec le 5 voà le fameux
bassin où vous avez les vertèbres
fusionnées donc tout ça c'est des
questions qu'on peut se poser grâce à ça
et donc on peut d'autres pistes du coup
pour faire dévoluer notre notre chic
osaurus exactement et qui au moins au
moins je crois ça ça doit être viable ça
parce que ça arrive justement
l'injection elle est quand même
relativement tard dans le développement
bah il faut déjà que tout soit développé
ouais donc donc ça à la limite tu tu tu
fais pas joujou avec les gènes en fait
tu fais juste joujou avec le mécanisme
c'est ça donc là là ça marche mais après
par contre pour rajouter des vertèbres
derrière faudrait faire joujou avec T
gèes ouais c'est ce qu'il disent là
justement tous les endroits où il y a de
la fusion où il pourrait tester c'est ça
donc là oui voilà il vous le montre là
les endroits avec les disques
intervertébraux et le pigostyle et c'est
là où on va avoir justement cette
inflammation contrôlée
h donc voilà si vous voulez si vous
voulez faire un archéoptérix un
archéoptérix un pouletosaur bah il faut
il faut agir sur tout ça donc faut faut
désenflammer la queue faut faut faire ça
sur un Kiama si vous voulez que ça
ressemble à un raptor il faut faut faire
des mutations qui feront pas des tibias
de travers à savoir qu'il pourra plus
voler he votre votre oiseau si vous
faites ça parce que il pourra plus faire
grand chose he non il pourra plus faire
grand chose à mon avis il va juste
rester replié dans un coin si survie il
va falloir trouver aussi d'où sort cette
d'ù quelles sont les mutations qui
permettent de faire réapparaître le
bassin siskia il
faudra faudra faire ça éventuellement
sur un noazzine et lui et l'empêcher de
de vieillir pour garder les griffes il
vous faudra bon encore les plumes on a
dit c'est pas la peine de trop y toucher
maintenant on sait que les la plupart
des opod avait des plumes donc ça ça va
vous êtes safe c'est bon mais vous
pouvez en rajouter si vous voulez parce
que on sait aussi au niveau du cerveau
vous pourrez pas faire grandchose oua
ouais pour les plumes tu peux en
rajouter tu peux rajouter des plumes ah
oui sur les pattes arrières oui et puis
pour faire 4 exactement et puis on sait
aussi justement comment changer les
endroits où les plumes apparaissent
parce que souvenez-vous qu'elles
apparaissent pas partout et si vous
voulez lui mettre des écas et des
endroits où il y a pas de plume de petit
rili c'est les endroits où les plumes
poussent il va falloir les faire
apparaître et ça on sait faire aussi h
ou bien les si vous fait un culinda
Dromeus pour faire disparaître les
plumes mais que sur la queue et
exactement ça aussi faut savoir faire VO
donc pour le cerveau on arrivera à rien
et
pour et c'est le cas de beaucoup de
monde c'est le cas de beaucoup de monde
on est tousy euh pour le palais et pour
le palais du coup on a les gênes il faut
juste arriver à faire grandir un un
embrion viable et avec des dents voilà
des dents qui sont un peu mieux que
juste des des morceaux de de truc
basique parce que ça c'est pas des d
vibl voilà tout ce qu'il vous faut pour
faire un pouletosaur la quantité de s
qu'il faut pour faire un on vous a donné
tous les trucs alors maintenant tous les
trucs qu'on a aujourd'hui en 2023 du
coup maintenant vos devoir chez vous
essayz de nous faire un pouletur correct
on vous a donné toute la méthode voilà
facile allez c'est bon c'est très mais
audelà de ça adelà de ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est l'opportunité
d'éducation que ça offre en fait c'estàd
que là on vient vraiment de passer en
revue la littérature sur qu'est-ce qui
sépare l'ISE
du du dinosaure typique en réalité c'est
pour ça que je me c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est aussi arrêté d'ailleurs sur
l'article sur les plumes h c'estàdire
que il y a le dinosaure typique de
l'imaginaire celui de Jurassic Park de
Jurassic World là le gros lézard tuant
et gluant on a pas trop vu de de gène du
gluant mais bon c'est trouvable
he mais bref c'est si vous voulez il y a
il y a le dinosaure de l'imaginaire avec
des griffes avec des dents avec des
écailles avec une longue queue du coup
avec tout ça tout ça et finalement bah
on constate en regardant la littérature
aujourd'hui en 2023 que la plupart de
ces caractères qui font que nos oiseaux
diffèrent aujourd'hui des de ce
dinosaure archétypal monstrueux bah
finalement il y a moyen il y a moyen je
veux dire de les de les il y a moyen de
les tweak comme ça là et finalement ça
veut dire que les oiseaux ils sont pas
si loin de cette idée du de
génétiquement parlant et
embryologiquement parlant ils sont pas
si loin de ce dinosaure archétypal et
donc de manière éducative si vous voulez
au niveau de l'éducation ça ça permet
quand même de bien montrer que
effectivement il y a une droite lignée
entre ce qu'on appelle un dinosaure et
ce qu'on appelle un oiseau aujourd'hui h
donc ça niveau éducation c'est c'est
quand même un outil c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut utiliser comme un outil
c'est pas comme je le disais de toute
façon et il faut toujours être bien
clair là-dessus le projet n'a jamais été
de faire revivre un
dinosaure le projet c'est de comprendre
l'évolution du développement l'évolution
et le développement des dinosaures et
des oiseaux et la transition des
premiers vers le second voilà j'espère
que vous avez appris plein de belles
choses sur le le pouletosaur des belles
choses je sais pas des trucs
intéressants en tout cas et puis ben
merci à toi miss plume et ben merci à to
et merci à vous tous et on se revoit
très bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut